daycare has been shown to harm the
ability to bond and feel secure
especially for babies their mental
health outcomes later in life are
impacted research proves this saying
this out loud can get you fired I post
this online and I get a flood of DMS
from people demanding answers and all I
do is pull up one of the longest running
studies in human history about daycare
conducted by the Canadian government and
just send them the link that shows how
daycare especially early in life and
especially in large amounts outcomes 10
20 years later in that child's life much
worse more anxiety more addictions more
broken relationships and broken
marriages more problems in their life
strongly correlated with that daycare
piece now does it definitively prove it
was just the daycare no was it massively
correlated in gigantic amounts that is
concerning absolutely what they've shown
is that even putting your kids with
Grandma or an aunt or a relative is even
better than putting them into daycare
with strangers that's what the Research
indicates